das ist wirklich ziemlich spektakulär
zum ersten mal ist die supraleitung bei
raumtemperatur gelungen das ganze ist so
etwas wie der heilige gral der
festkörperphysik strom ohne widerstand
bei raumtemperatur leighton bislang
schien es unmöglich und das trotz
intensiver forschung doch eine us
forschungsteam ist jetzt der durchbruch
gelungen die fachleute präsentieren an
material das elektrischen strom
verlustfrei leitet und das achtung bei
raumtemperatur dennoch gibt es an haken
links hans future gibt es dreimal pro
woche spannendes heinz videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
so verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen das ist eine echte
premiere denn es scheint so als hätten
us fachleute nun ein jahrelanges ziel
der physik erreicht zum ersten mal
überhaupt ist es wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler nämlich gelungen an
material zu entwickeln dass strom ohne
widerstand leitet und das bei
raumtemperatur darüber berichtet sogar
das renommierte fachmagazin nature als
titelgeschichte und dieser durchbruch
ist wirklich spektakulär denn es ist
keine übertreibung wenn ich sage
supraleiter haben das potenzial die welt
wie wir sie kennen zu revolutionieren
denn die super leitfähigkeit verhilft
materialien zu zwei entscheidenden
eigenschaften
zum einen geht der elektrische
widerstand verloren und elektronen
können in diesem zustand ohne verluste
geleitet werden zum anderen stoßen diese
materialien magnetfelder ab magnetfeld
dienen werden also um das material herum
gelenkt und das heißt im klartext dass
supraleiter deswegen auf einem
magnetfeld schweben
möglich würden damit also viel einfacher
nicht nur magnetschwebebahn mit hilfe
von supraleitenden materialien die bei
raumtemperatur funktionieren könnten
beispielsweise auch äußerst effiziente
quantencomputer und das in großer menge
und viel leichter produziert werden denn
supraleitende materialien sind wichtig
für die konstruktion der quanten bits
der cubes aber auch andere elektrische
geräte die sehr leistungsfähig sind
könnten mit hilfe dieser technik
optimiert werden denn das problem einer
drohenden überhitzung könnte durch den
ansatz supraleitender material
denn ausgeschlossen werden denn
stromleitungen ohne widerstand werden
nicht warum die verluste stromleitung
könnten quasi richtung null gehen und
hier gibt es ja tatsächlich noch eine
menge einsparpotenzial in deutschland
gehen jedes jahr vier prozent des stroms
so verloren das sind 24 karat stunden
das sind 24 milliarden kilowattstunden
eine riesige menge uns verbraucher würde
das mehr als sieben milliarden euro
kosten wenn wir das zum verkaufspreis
bezahlen müssen und schon heute werden
supraleiter eingesetzt beispielsweise in
der magnetresonanztomographie oder in
teilchenbeschleunigern doch bislang
müssen sie enorm aufwendig gekühlt
werden
denn ihren elektrischen widerstand
verlieren sie erstmal sehr kalten
temperaturen ziemlich nahe nicht mehr so
nah aber immer noch nahe dem absoluten
nullpunkt von minus 273 15 grad celsius
dazu der us physiker ranga diaz ein
supraleiter zu entdecken der bei
raumtemperatur funktioniert ist so etwas
wie der heilige gral der
festkörperphysik es ist ein problem das
über hundert jahre altes manchmal haben
wir schon gedacht oh das ist ja gar
nicht möglich in diesem sinne ist es
eine fundamentale entdeckung das
bestätigt auch sein finnischer kollege
chris pk der die neue entdeckung aus den
usa auf der nachrichtenseite des
fachmagazins science als zitat
meilenstein beschreibt und so konnten
auch die beteiligten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
ihren augen kaum trauen als sie die
messkurve das erste mal genauer in
augenschein nahm denn der elektrische
widerstand ihrer probe war plötzlich auf
null gesunken
denn genau das ist das typische
charakteristik um eine super leiters
doch anders als bei den bisherigen
wissenschaftlichen experimenten in
diesem bereich fand das experiment von
ranga diaz und seinem team praktisch bei
raumtemperatur statt
wir waren also keineswegs extreme
temperaturen von mindestens minus 200
grad celsius notwendig damit der
supraleiter funktionierte die temperatur
bei diesem experiment lag stattdessen
bei stolzen plus 15 grad celsius also so
wie wir es ungefähr im moment ausnahmen
und genau das schien bislang
unerreichbar die entdeckung ist also ein
großer fortschritt das zeigt auch die
geschichte der langen so
nach einem super leiter der bei
raumtemperatur funktioniert ein rätsel
dass vor allem die physikerinnen und
physiker im bereich der festkörper schon
seit fast 100 jahren beschäftigt denn
bereits 1911 hatte ein holländischer
wissenschaftler entdeckt das quecksilber
sein widerstand verlor als es mit hilfe
von flüssigem helium bis auf minus 269
grad herunter gekühlt wurde
es dauerte rund 50 jahre bis die
fachwelt diese beobachtungen erklären
konnte
demnach liegt der verlustfreie
stromfluss an der paarung von elektronen
diese überwinden am absoluten
temperaturnullpunkt bei minus 273 15
grad celsius ihre gegenseite
elektrostatische abstoßung somit wandern
sie dann paarweise und reibungsfrei
durch das kristallgitter später konnte
die super leitung dann auch bei anderen
materialien aufgespürt werden die
nächste große entdeckung erfolgte dann
vor 34 jahren 19 86 durch
forschungsteams von ibm
die fachleute hatten erstmals eine
nichtmetallische keramischen supraleiter
aufgespürt seine sprungtemperatur liegt
bei minus 238 grad die jagd nach immer
wärmeren supraleitern ging somit in die
heiße phase von 19 jahren 2001 hatten
fachleute dann magnesium die brit
genauer ins visier genommen seitdem weiß
man dass sich diese einfache verbindung
wie ein klassischer supraleiter verhält
konkret bedeutet das dass magnesium die
porit bereits bei minus 2 134 grad vom
normal leitenden in den supraleitenden
zustand wechselt klar ist dennoch auch
der genaue mechanismus der hinter der
hochtemperatur supraleitung steckt ist
bisher noch weitgehend unklar
hochsprung temperaturen aber sind doch
möglich wie wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler vom max-planck-institut
für chemie aus mainz vor sechs jahren
erstmals bewiesen hatten sie hatten eine
schwefelwasserstoff verbindung bei minus
70 grad zum supraleiter gemacht das
geheimnis dahinter ein extrem hoher
druck notwendig weil hier eindruck von
25 megawatt die fachleute gehen davon
aus dass dieser hohe druck die
wasserstoffreichen verbindungen in einen
metallischen zustand bringen
im vergangenen jahr gab es dann eine
weitere erfolgsmeldung vom team des max
planck instituts für chemie in mainz die
fachleute um den wissenschaftler michael
rms
hatten den rekord für die hochtemperatur
supraleitung bei minus 70 grad celsius
geknackt dafür hatten sie dann betritt
synthetisiert das unter sehr hohem druck
sogar schon bei minus 23 grad celsius
seinen elektrischen widerstand verliert
darüber haben wir damals ausführlich
berichtet die proben wurden in einer nur
einigen hundert kubikmeter kleinen
kammer eindruck von 1,7 megawatt
ausgesetzt das entspricht dem 1,7
millionen fachen atmosphärendruck hier
auf der erde
dann könnten die fachleute die probe ab
und tatsächlich bei einer temperatur von
minus 23 grad celsius sank der
elektrische widerstand des materials auf
null
und wirklich auf nummer sicher zu gehen
dass es sich tatsächlich um supraleitung
handelt wurden zudem auch messungen in
einem äußeren magnetfeld durchgeführt
denn diese stören die supraleitung der
übergang verschiebt sich durch den
einfluss eines magnetfeldes zu
niedrigeren temperaturen und genau das
war in diesem experiment der fall der
mainzer forscher michael metz bezeichnet
die neue entdeckung aus den usa übrigens
als großen fortschritt die
amerikanischen kolleginnen und kollegen
hatten das in mainz entwickelte material
tatsächlich auf gut glück durch
kohlenstoff ergänzt enthalten sind
außerdem auch wasserstoff und schwefel
diese stoff kombination platzierte das
os forschungsteam dann zwischen zwei
feine spitzen aus diamant zudem wurde
grünes laserlicht eingesetzt und die
reaktion anzuregen in die hoch
druckkammer ließen die fachleute dann
wasserstoffgas einströmen so kam es zu
einer chemischen reaktion bei der sie
schwefelwasserstoff und methan bildeten
über die diamant spitzen konnten die
forscherinnen forscher den druck auf die
probe immer weiter erhöhen da die
diamanten selbst wie ambosse wirken
in einem ersten schritt bildet sie sich
zunächst ein flüssiges gemisch das nach
und nach fester wurde oberhalb von
40.000 bar formte sich dann ein kristall
doch die fachleute machten weiter und
presst die diamanten immer weiter
zusammen zudem fuhren sie die temperatur
immer weiter runter
die überraschung war groß denn der
gefrierpunkt musste in diesem experiment
nicht einmal unterschritten werden
bereits bei einer temperatur von plus 15
grad celsius wurde die probe
supraleitend der druck hier bei 2,7
millionen war ein irrsinniger wert der
in der praxis so nicht erreicht werden
kann weitere experimente bestätigten
dann dass es sich tatsächlich um den
supraleitenden zustand handelt zum einen
konnte dies auch hier wieder mit hilfe
eines von außen angelegten magnetfelds
demonstriert werden zum anderen viele
elektrische widerstand von jetzt auf
gleich auf den wert 0 auch das ist ein
typisches merkmal eines super lagers
nach ansicht der wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftler ist dieser weltrekord
wohl vor allem auf die ist aline
struktur des methans schwefelwasserstoff
gemische zurückzuführen methan und
schwefelwasserstoff könnten
möglicherweise immer abwechselnd feste
kita plätze in kristallen besetzten in
den zwischenräumen dagegen sind
möglicherweise wasserstoff atome
eingelagert spektroskopische analysen
dass es ausschließen
dennoch sind auch andere
kristallstrukturen denkbar wie man sich
den kristall aufbau genauer vorstellen
kann wollen die physikerinnen und
physiker jetzt in der kommenden zeit
untersuchen eine enorm wichtige
forschungsfrage denn erkenntnisse in
diesem bereich könnten uns bei der suche
nach raumtemperatur super leitern die
sogar bei eher geringem druck ihren
widerstand verlieren nach vorne bringen
mit diesen neuen erkenntnissen aus den
usa hat ist der heilige gral der
festkörperphysik also noch nicht ganz
gefunden denn das wäre ein supraleiter
das material das nicht nur bei
raumtemperatur funktioniert sondern auch
unter geringerem druck dennoch auch
diese entdeckung der ersten super
leitung bei raumtemperatur ist ein
entscheidender meilenstein da sagt auch
dass us forschungsteam selbst wegen der
notwendigkeit einer kühlung konnten
super leiter materialien die die welt
bisher nicht in dem maße transformieren
wie es sich viele vorgestellt haben aber
unsere entdeckung reiste nun diese
barrieren ein und öffnet die tür zu
vielen neuen potenziellen anwendungen
dennoch gibt es noch viel zu tun um auch
praktische anwendungen zu ermöglichen
dafür muss vor allem der druck der
benötigt wird deutlich verringert werden
das os forschungsteam ist optimistisch
dass dies gelingen kann dazu schreibt
das forschungsteam in seiner aktuellen
studie ein chemisches tuning unseres
steuersystems könnte die eigenschaften
der raumtemperatur super leistung bei
geringerem druck erhalten und in diesem
video hoch temperaturrekord supraleitung
bei raumtemperatur da geht es um den
letzten rekord von 2009 10
auch der war schon bahnbrechend also
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren und
zwar die
ein kanal pixum santa lucia bis dann
bleibt dran